Naturally, we don't like feeling uncomfortable. Therefore we're motivated to
try to decrease that overall level of discomfort. Remember in the lesson on
consciousness, I talked about drugs? And specifically I talked about all the
negative effects of smoking tobacco. In that lesson I asked students who were
smokers to consider that negative information. And I did so in a hopes to try
to motivate some people to quit smoking. Now what happens when you realize
there are negative consequences for smoking? Well, we want to decrease those
negative feelings that we experience. So how do we do this? Well, there are
three options that we can use to help to decrease the discomfort that we
experience. And the first is that we can change our behavior to make it more
consistent with our dissonant cognition. So here for example the person may try
to quit smoking using a nicotine patch or perhaps a self help group. The second
way we can do so is to try to justify our behavior. And to justify our
behavior, we try to make our cognitions more consistent with the behavior that
we're engaging in. So the person may say to themselves that smoking's not that
bad for me and all that research is mostly correlational. And the third way we
can attempt to decrease said discomfort is by adding new cognitions that are
consistent and support our behavior. Here the person may say, I just enjoy
smoking and I think it's worth it, therefore I'm not concerned about the risks.